[Music]
money-hungry news pottery monies would
you do you not like money got a work man
all day every day every day wake up go
to bed work every day bro all that [ __ ]
it's like everybody on YouTube drives me
[ __ ] nuts dude I just saw the video
you said a bond you think everyone talks
about how hard they work and then I'm
like you shoot music videos all day no
this is my favorite vlog channel I work
so hard I'm so tired I worked so hard
I'm so tired I'm so tired it's over and
over every vlog is I work so hard
I'm so tired it's like a go to work
every day every day you gotta attack you
know the popular word now is hustling
yeah hustling the unpopular underlying
note is called cocaine yes somebody I J
can come to Paris we were just renewing
about yeah Taylor Swift has sparked
outrage as fans are told to buy her
merch and new album to gain points to be
able to purchase her show tickets why is
that sparked outrage it's just like just
clever marketing yeah they can earn
points by a buying merch that they were
probably already buy why you have to buy
merch or something no so the thing is
Taylor Collette is collaborating with
Ticketmaster on this program where it's
supposed to help regulate the ticket
sales against the scalpers in the box oh
actually I'm gonna show you guys a video
okay that she posted on her Twitter that
explains it all here we go
explain it away Katie we've all been
there Taylor Swift tickets are about to
go on sale your command center is ready
I wasn't answer email address in their
password entered your favorite
well then go time comes and it's a race
against the clock and the bots not just
every seat your seat it's time to beat
the bots Taylor wants you at the show
going crazy with your friends screaming
every word that's why we're excited to
announce a new way of buying tickets a
better way a fun way using Taylor Swift
and creepy powered by Ticketmaster
verified fan made for you the fans visit
Taylor Swift comm register and unlock
access to the Taylor Swift tix portal
once at the portal you can choose your
preferred City to see the show then
you'll have the opportunity to
participate in unique activities your
spot in line based on the activities you
participate in your place in line will
move up and down dissipate
do your thing yeah only rich people can
come to my concert no that's kind of
[ __ ] up it's pretty good it's kind of
stop it up out there if you verify
yourself as a fan yeah you can buy up to
two tickets then the bots are doing that
though that's true oh really but there's
no like real proof that this will even
work against the bots either you know
the fans are really upset because
they're just like what the [ __ ] is this
like I have to since the the your place
in line changes based on how much
however merchandise merchandise or
activities are these points that you get
but other people are also doing the same
so then your place changes any if you
have more money you can just get more
points so the fans are like wait what
the [ __ ] is this like all of a sudden
like our relationship is about money
yeah what if they did stuff that wasn't
like about money but it was like oh I've
been to her concert this many times or
like or maybe maybe if it's like writing
an essay or write in a read this nerd AG
guy wants to write an essay for kids
you know you gotta put in work you got
to do something like to to prove that
you're a human being you're looking guy
on that in a nerd cartoon series who's
like you don't know solve this problem
mathematics Jesus the interesting thing
is it's like you have a choice to buy
the tickets or not like honestly you
don't let it nobody's forcing you that's
why that's the weird part for me it's
like it's a consumer choice you know if
you love her and you want to go then
you'll buy it if you don't like her that
much then just basically raise the price
of tickets because you have to have have
bought a certain amount of merchandise
to have your place in line be farther
and then in that place in line isn't
even guaranteeing you a CD baby it's
definitely not guaranteeing your parking
spot possessions forty bucks - maybe
it's because I'm not a Taylor Swift fan
that's why you need to be like just
think of it any other artist yeah you
you want to go see them that would be
nobody see David exactly that's the
problem we're not fans of anyone okay
you have to put yourself in the head
let's see I love under elements so much
he bought the merch I would have bought
them with you would you have spent like
70 grand for it absolutely not see
that's that it's not worth it to me
that's that's what people are pissed
about because all the bots are buying it
and then they're jacking it up by like
crazy yeah and then only rich people can
afford it I see I'm starting to
understand this it's not her shirt - a
[ __ ] 80 bucks
she's just shifting the money [ __ ] do
you Taylor sweaty but this whole buy
stuff to get better tix ain't cute my
ass just wants to see Taylor I'm not a
damn bot okay miss Swift
I could tell because you put an s after
tix it's already plural with the ex it's
fine those bots are getting smart Taylor
Swift this is [ __ ] up and money-hungry
pre-ordered the album and buy merch and
you can get in line to get tickets
hashtag look what you made me do so she
did it anyway
using Taylor Swift's new thing look at
your new song I'm sorry way to creep up
on hot coals why does this she just make
the tickets more expensive you think the
bots will still buy it yeah they will
they'll just make it even more fans 'is
the only thing I don't like about Taylor
tix is that they prioritize people who
spend more money on merch less albums
which not everyone has see I understand
you now that's [ __ ] up like I just
want to be there to support you but the
reason why you're stopping me is because
you're telling me I'm too poor Taylor
Swift I don't think that people are
really getting it like I think people
are getting mad before they really
understand the situation because what's
happening is there's say a thousand
tickets and a bot buys all of them they
went from $75 to now they're 300 if you
were too poor to buy that $300 ticket
you weren't gonna get in anyways like
and then you're also gonna be too poor
to buy her merch like if you're too poor
you're just not gonna get into a Taylor
Swift concert what she's doing is
shifting the money from the box to to
herself you're gonna get in what about
the fans we legally download all your
[ __ ] Taylor yeah weren't you thinking to
them ever
it doesn't matter like you weren't gonna
get in cuz the scalper is gonna resell
it for - higher than that you can afford
like so are there fans that actually get
it for normal price or are the thoughts
just immediate because if this was the
case why are people outraged but at the
box and saying like yeah finally we cuz
they can't control the body and you can
tweet it as much as you want it'll never
change this is the supply chain it goes
Ticketmaster - BOTS - fans mom - fan
I thought Ticketmaster was the bots no
no the supply they supply the ticket and
then the fans mom or dad purchases the
ticket and so that's why the fans never
really care about the money unless they
got a bank mom and dad which is a lot of
work and like it's like mom and dad
please it's like 600 bucks a ticket so
ultimately this might be a lower cost
per ticket yeah it might be cheaper for
them then if that's the case then Taylor
I'm sorry I called you a [ __ ]
no other thing is it's still not a
guarantee and BOTS can still possibly
buy all this [ __ ] in
matter what the people that are buying
March they'll still be in the same
position no matter what because there's
no guarantee or even you get a ticket
let alone get to choose where you get to
see it sit so then that's why a lot of
people are so really angry because it's
like I have to spend extra money on your
merch and I still don't even have a
guarantee well you don't whether this
program happens or not like bots are
buying it out people like the demand is
way too high compared to the supply so
it still doesn't matter like you still
have no guarantee there are no
guarantees in life anyways you should
write an essay yeah I told you is the
essay will solve problems no books did
you write game of throne bucks they can
write when BuzzFeed was trying to get a
comment from a hand write the [ __ ]
essay how about that and mail it when
serious journalist outlet BuzzFeed was
trying to do so they were trying to get
comment and then they just referred to
them to the official terms and
conditions of the Taylor Swift tix
and so what it says there in bulbs and
in capitalized and all in caps
it says no purchase or boost activity is
necessary to enter or receive an access
code a purchase or payment of any kind
will not increase your chances so even
in the terms it says you don't need to
do this but it's still really encouraged
so it's like so confusing and that's why
fans are upset because this whole
process is just oh they could still
purchase a ticket without it yeah so
apparently what they like a sweepstakes
think you just have to register yourself
as a verified fan and then you'll get an
access code to purchase tickets once
they're available but then what's the
point system that's the part of
confusing feels like what would it was
happening well I mean like well that's
cool then cuz now it's like it's like
you're paying for VIP tickets then it's
just by getting merged right you're just
shifting the money you know it's not
BOTS doing the same people they got a
ride an essay I'm telling you
yeah so if you could buy the tickets
without having to do that then you're
still in the same place you were before
if I was her I wouldn't care because
regardless if [ __ ] bots are buying it
someone's buying it yeah you're still
getting yeah they're buying this rich
[ __ ] she's gonna stay that way more
money though the numbers are making more
do you think it's her decision or her
life somebody a management company so
she went against Spotify and what was it
iTunes upendra another one like
sputtering someone else cuz she was like
you're not the terms I [ __ ] up you
people are listening to my music for
free and I'm not getting [ __ ] out of it
and then she protested against that so
she already thinks she's money hungry
she takes on YouTube parody videos all
the time like her team's crazy with that
with that stuff Oh her song yeah like
they get like two even when they're good
I'm really they go out they go after
parodies all the time yeah or the other
thing used to well no it used to get you
money on YouTube at home it's funny that
she is Katy Perry's fan branding for the
video cuz like Katy Perry's fans are
cats Taylor Swift fans are snakes
they're snakes
well they're like big kind of are now
kim kardashian drama others called her a
snake and then now like all her fans are
like putting the snake emoji on where's
the name Kim K was when I called her
Slayer because you have national snake
date or something there's a days for
people I mean things who likes her music
12 year old girls you know grown man
have been known to tap it foot to a
little bit and we know then there's a
there's a catchy tune to it could you be
you know I bet you I bet you a formula
there I know I bet you I do I just have
to hear I know the blank spaces one
which ones that housing we've all done
it hey you know what I know that song
the only time I bump Taylor Swift was
when I first moved to LA I had my Camry
I got lost and I was in South Central
Content area and then I was at a
stoplight and then it was on the radio
and the guy came up to me and he said
turn that [ __ ] off you [ __ ] [ __ ]
and I turned it down and I rolled up my
window and I went about my way and then
you went 20 feet and your turret right
back welcome to LA huh hey you guys want
to stock any of us we'll go ahead down
to the description box below and you can
follow us on Instagram and all kinds of
stuff for more videos
[Music]
[Music]